sun is up it's shining you know that sun
is up now before 6 30 and we're getting
these longer spring days yesterday was a
long day with all the wind that was
blowing but it finally was calming down
by dinner time temperatures are in the
very or the cooler 50s and even low 50s
seven hills and mountains edge it's a
little chilly out there so might want to
put on some long sleeves a very light
jacket 45 out at red rock 38 up at kyle
canyon and winds are still blowing along
the river today laughlin and bullhead
city both have been getting some gusts
to 30 miles an hour no wind advisories
but still blustery down there 85 degrees
today we were at 77 yesterday so very
normal for early april but now we start
the warm up again and we're going to
head towards record high territory as we
get into the weekend so the west is
pretty clear we've got high wind
warnings through the middle of the
country and a big cold front that
stretches from eastern canada all the
way along the east coast and down to a
west of florida in the gulf of mexico
along it lots of rain showers
thunderstorms two to three inches of
rain expected in the northeast today the
southeast is starting to calm down after
another round of severe weather a 45
tornadoes spotted across the southeast
on tuesday and then more tornadoes in
georgia yesterday they've got tornado
warnings right now north of daytona
beach this one this rope tornado was in
a little place called leslie georgia
check it out these storm chasers were
right on this muddy road
just capturing this video of the tornado
it turned out that it was about
this was about 40 miles north of albany
it did skip across the field it damaged
a couple of vehicles it did produce some
damage but no one was injured thankfully
that's just a scary sight so it looks
like there's going to be some more
severe weather to damage reported here
in northern florida before that line of
showers and thunderstorms finally exits
the east coast back in the west high
pressure sunny skies
temperatures over the next couple of
three days in southern california are
going to get into the mid to upper 90s
we've got mid 80s coming today 90s back
by tomorrow and saturday for us in las
vegas even laughlin is going to be in
the upper 90s by saturday but then
another chilly system from the pacific
brings more wind starting sunday look
how the temperatures drop even to low
70s by tuesday could be some
neighborhoods don't get out of the 60s
on tuesday man what a difference